a community in grief
the family of Tyree Nichols joined in at
a Memphis State Park to honor the father
who was an avid skateboarder his mother
calling for calm ahead of the release of
a police video of the events which led
to her son's death
and if you guys are here for me and
Tyree then you will protest peacefully
police initially said Nichols died in
hospital after a confrontation with
officers
the lawyers of the family say nickel was
pepper sprayed tasered restrained and
kicked the last words
on the video
he's only about
80 to 100
yards from his house
and he calls for his mom
three times mom
he's called for his mom and so
where's the humanity
these are the five officers who've been
charged with second-degree murder
they're also facing charges of
aggravated assault aggravated kidnapping
official misconduct and official
oppression they were fired last week
after an investigation found them to be
directly responsible for using excessive
force we all want the same thing we want
Justice
for Tyree Nichols
it's my hope that if there is any
Silver Lining to be drawn from this very
dark cloud it's that perhaps this
incident can open a broader conversation
about the need for police reform the
city is
Rael